are you officially a part of blink-182
uh I like to think so yes yes blink-182
is one of the most influential rock fans
in the world
but when conflicting stories came out
about whether former member Tom DeLonge
quit the band fans weren't sure what the
future held
it's been a year and a half of
speculation and what's it gonna sound
like and is this gonna sound like blink
and what's blink really about and I
think this record really really shows
people that we are blink 182 do you guys
feel like this is a rebirth of blink 182
or is it more of a an evolution I feel
like it's a fresh start
I feel like this album really takes us
back to a blink is all about it's a
rebirth in that it feels like old blink
but in a new presentation if that makes
sense
the band's new single bored to death
proves just that
from my point of view it was sort of a
response to Marc's call in the first
verse of traversing a relationship and
kind of navigating through it when
things get real murky you know it's
easier to see your board or to be angry
than this to be sad blink is gearing up
for a new tour and the band's seventh
studio album California is out July 1st
I feel like it might if you had to
compare two of our albums it's kind of
like innama the state meets the untitled
album but it has a lot of the same
tempos as I guess dude ranch does
there's a ballad so yeah there is a
ballad it's called homeless such a
lonely place which is one of my favorite
lyrics on the record as well but it just
brings a very lonely feeling whether
lyrics can you tease I want to see some
naked dudes that's why I built this pool
that's who that's by the way that's the
entire lyric for a whole song the good
reason that Shelton
I choked up over each other okay I think
teenage satellites has memorable there
yeah it's a good like teen anthem we're
gonna go and break things oh yeah